two-way tables despite how sort of
ordinary they seem to be are actually
key to helping work out when people are
lying to you let me give you an example
okay all right so someone tell me who
we're looking at please oh you guys you
guys okay so this is um this is Reggie
Miller okay Reggie Miller now I'm
low-key disappointed that no one got his
name because okay I know Michael Jordan
is one of the most famous OOP of all
time but both Miller and Jordan in the
NBA all-stars Hall of Fame all I can
think right now they were both renowned
for their accuracy this shot accuracy
okay and I want to ask the question well
who was more accurate okay now most
people would assume okay
Michael Jordan but I want to see if I
can push on that assumption let's think
about this way okay you want to
understand accuracy you want to break
down the numbers right so of course on
in a normal game of basketball there's
two different kinds of shots you can
take there's two pointers and then
there's three pointers right if you're
inside the circle semi circle two points
if you're at sides three right I'm not
gonna count free-throws because I'm kind
of like you know I'm just gonna put that
to one side probably because I don't
think that kind of partly also because I
didn't have diner about them okay now
that aside have a look at these numbers
for a second now I didn't know about you
but the first time I saw these numbers
just on paper I was like really like
he's just barely breaking half right
like that's not that doesn't sound that
impressive but actually when you think
about it of course when you're comparing
who he's playing up against these are
very very impressive numbers okay there
are a few people there are a few people
who can get even close to a comparison
with this okay however the reason why I
put Reggie Miller on here is because he
is one of those people here are Miller's
numbers now now just have a look at this
okay now this is this is we've got this
out of there historical data okay now
what we'll come to will come to how this
came about but let's check into this
first look at the numbers on the face of
it for me they look pretty clear don't
they they look pretty clear the
understandable they're not it's not
massive margins particular in your two
pointers but they are margins
nonetheless do you agree and in fact on
the three point is that that's I think
that's an impressive difference right so
this is a big deal how can we understand
whether this claim is legitimate or not
okay well let's push on this a little
more and use the tool that we've been
talking about today right let's break
this down by way of a two way table
because it's actually a lot hiding
underneath these percentages
okay how do you get a percentage like 52
percent where's that come from what do
you think that means
very good so it's the number of shots
that he successfully gets in a hoop
versus the total number of shots that he
takes right so we would call them the
ones he gets him we call them goals all
of the shots that he takes me just on
shots right so if you had to think about
goals versus shots over time what
they've done is they've actually done a
comparison rather than over like adding
up every single one there had a look per
game can I say that again because these
numbers are going to confuse you
otherwise they're had a little per game
how many shots each player took and then
how many they actually say does that
make sense okay so let's have a look at
some of Miller's numbers what does this
mean in an average game in an average
game Miller takes seven point nine shots
from inside on an average game right so
one game he takes seven the next game he
takes 10 the next game he takes two they
average it all out does that make sense
this is career-wise actually the whole
thing okay so seven point nine is how
many takes on average four point one is
how many he gets so do you see what the
52% comes wrong Sammy that's okay cool
here his numbers on three-pointers okay
three-pointers everything so far so good
okay now before I show you the next few
numbers I do want to mention I'm asking
who is more accurate there's no argument
who scored more points overall Michael
Jordan just wipes the floor with
everyone okay so these numbers are going
to be bigger but I'm interested in
accuracy yeah have a look at Jordans
numbers now okay
so immediately you can see he takes many
many more shots many more shots okay
interesting where he doesn't take nearly
as many from the three-pointer anyone
want to tell me why
say it again time it's too risky right
and also a player like Jordan he can
just you can just drive in there he's so
good at doing that and you can do that
over and over again so the risk reward
is not worth it okay so he actually
takes fewer three-pointers okay now come
back to this example here what did we do
with this that enabled us to make some
sense of this well we didn't actually
write it because I kind of like skipped
over it right
but this 2.6 percent came from not 26
divided by like these whole numbers it
was 26 divided by a specific number did
you notice that we stayed within the
condition so this is 26 divided by 988
all right and this one here was what was
that seven divided by seven fifty yes
okay so the power of a two-way table is
it sort of unpacks within these
categories there's more going on so let
me show you what's going on actually
I'll do better than that I want you to
help me you've got the numbers here
you've got calculators there can you go
ahead and I'm interested in the total
number of actual goals that each player
sang per game and the total number of
actual shots that they sank per game can
I give you about 60 seconds you can work
with the person next to you so you don't
have to do all the numbers just
calculate them and please write them
down I actually want you to write down
Miller's total shots versus goals and
then Jordan's total shots versus goals I
need you to write it down you'll see why
in a second can I get another show of
hands now who's done with the four
numbers hands up this is the Edition yep
okay thank you thank you hands down all
right so let me help you out or actually
let me ask you did you get these numbers
so what you got okay now the reason I
asked you to write these numbers down
it's so that we can do this same kind of
calculation right because now I've got
totals to compare against I've got
totals the total accuracy should be the
total number of actual goals scored
versus the toner number of shots per
game does that make sense
you can divide them and you can get
percentages just like these go ahead and
do it and then as soon as you calculate
those two percentages their percentages
now just just give me a nod you've got
it yep okay
anyone else do the calculation get the
percentages that's what i'ma start
tomorrow view calculate them yet I'm
looking for these percentages turn a
number of goals over turn on with shots
per game for both players many of you've
already arrived at these numbers
yourselves but some of you have it so
pens out of hands calculator is down
just look with me okay if you go ahead
and you calculate you can see it's close
can't you ready I'm waiting for eyes up
just almost there very good these are
the actual totals right you're like wait
a second just wait a second
Jordan is down on both numbers compared
to me life but somehow you add
everything then you go ahead
double-check triple-check right Jordans
in front right which is you know
understandably wise so happy how can
this be okay now there's actually really
important I'd like you to write this
down you can research it later this
phenomenon has a name it's called this
is the hare I want you to write down
it's called Simpsons paradox Simpsons
paradox now this is weird when people
see it for the first time when I saw it
the first time I was like but how how
can that make sense how can you get to
lower numbers add them together and
somehow get a bigger number okay I'll
show you just look carefully at this for
a second it takes a second to absorb
what's going on okay so here's a big
data set okay now if you have a look at
the big the whole data set what you can
see is this downward trend yeah you can
see the downward trend from top left to
bottom right okay but if you then take a
subset carefully within the data you can
see that each of those five subsets that
they color independently they've got
upward trends do you see that I'll say
that one more time the whole data set
has a clear downward trend but then if
you cherry-pick correctly and you pick
your subcategories in a clever way you
can actually make the data look like
it's saying the opposite in fact the
other name for this is the reversal
paradox okay and this is what I mean by
people lying to you with numbers if you
had a look back at all of this right
remember the first few numbers I showed
you looks pretty clear didn't that looks
pretty clear the to a table was
tall we could use to actually unpack
what on earth is going on how am I
actually having the wool pulled over my
eyes all I need to do to trick you is to
pick the right subset of data and only
show you that it's that make sense